[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with columnist
carol malone and political editor of the
liverpool echo liam thought they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
well the telegraph leads with the bank
of england predicting inflation will
climb to 11
later this year prompting the chancellor
to indicate tax cuts will be put on hold
the bank of england raising its interest
base rate to the highest point since the
start of 2009 is also on the front of
the metro with the headline 11
hell is on the way
the express goes with soaring inflation
and a real fall in wages could see food
builds leap this summer with industry
experts warning prices will rocket by 15
boris johnson is considering scrapping
the role of ethics advisor after the
resignation of lord guyt reports the
guardian
the fd goes with the leaders of france
germany italy and romania pledging to
back ukraine's bid to apply for eu
membership after meeting president
vladimir zelinsky in kiev
convicted sex trafficker gelaine maxwell
believes she deserves to go free in just
over two years that's according to the
daily mirror
and the daily star splashes on a warning
not to drink too much alcohol as parts
of the uk bus in sizzling temperatures
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by columnist
carol malone and political editor of the
liverpool echo liam thorpe welcome to
you both let's start with the telegraph
and that's prediction from the bank of
england that inflation could hit 11
carol
it's terrifying you know i mean you know
hell is the right word for this you know
we're going to have really tough times
to come we've been talking about tough
times now for months i'm coming we we
didn't really know what that was going
to feel like or how it was going to be
now we know we know that interest rates
you know there are 1.3 million people
currently who's those fixed rate
mortgages are going to expire this year
and those people are going to have to
find a new deal and the problem has been
for a lot of householders that we all
borrowed really more than we can afford
because interest rates were at a
historic low and they have been for 13
years it's it's it's incredible and and
so now even the slightest rate even a
0.25 raised is going to put many
families in trouble and with all those
fixed rates ending this year it's going
to be a real problem for people
yes and the bank says expect the
consumer prices index that's the
official measure of inflation to be a
little above
the 2 target in two years time so
further
gloomy predictions liam
yeah as you say jillian the the bank of
england's target is two percent we're
we're at nine percent now we're looking
at 11 by october when we we have
obviously got the
another rise in the in the energy cap
that's going to come and and a really
difficult winter for so so many people i
think the other thing to say is that the
bank of england is obviously doing what
it can do which is to
to to raise interest rates to try and
bring down that inflation but
a lot of this inflation is being caused
by things in some ways out of its
control we've got soaring energy prices
we've got the issues being caused by war
in ukraine we've got supply chain issues
being caused by brexit so in some ways
we're not even sure that that these
measures that the bank of england is
taking are actually going to have the
desired effect of bringing in in
bringing inflation rates down so
we're kind of in uncharted territory and
i think there's there's a lot of people
a lot of households who'd be extremely
worried certainly as we kind of come
through the summer the extra energy cap
rise we head into the winter you know
there'll be a lot of people who'd be
extremely worried right now that we're
headed into a really really difficult
period yeah an official [ __ ] sorry go
ahead carol i was just gonna i was just
gonna say that the the bank of england
andrew billy he was very careful today
not to say that there would be more
interest rate rises but the phrase he
used was that he would respond and the
bank would respond forcibly um to signs
to signs of higher inflation and we know
that's going to happen inflation is
going to go up and actually the bank you
know liam is saying it's it's a lot of
its forces beyond their control but the
bank has been criticized heavily for not
moving quickly enough to to to
to rising prices and to the over heating
in the market so it's you know i don't
know who's to blame here but i just i
just know that a lot of people are going
to be very very worried tonight you know
and i can remember interest rates you
know when i was in my 20s of 17
so when people say it's gonna rise to
three and a half percent it doesn't
sound a lot but it is a lot if you've
been used to paying 1.5 percent some of
those fixed rate mortgages for two years
were like 1.2 percent 1.7
they don't exist anymore in the last two
or three months they they have gone up
threefold so now those mortgages are
going to be like 2.5
so it's going to make it's going to make
living doubly hard for people who are
struggling to pay their their bills
currently the food is going to rocket
rishi sunak has already said that
there's going to be no tax cuts until
2024 just in time for the next election
um so you know people are just going to
be hit from all ends and sides here
scary it's really scary yeah data's
suggesting that there will be
no economic growth next year the metro
describing it uh is 11 as hell is on the
way
liam
yeah i mean just to to come back on what
carol said there i'm quite a good
example of what she was just talking
about we were i'm a new homeowner and
fortunate fortunate enough to have been
able to to buy our first home we're on a
fixed rate mortgage but that deal is
coming to an end in july then we're
gonna have to renegotiate if we were to
be on a very great mortgage like a lot
of people we would be succumbing to all
of the inflationary pressures that we're
gonna that we're gonna face in terms of
the interest rate rising and we would
face the income rate rising at a time
when rule is soaring
when uh when food prices are soaring you
know me and my partner we we got in the
car the other day and we put 30 quid in
um and the the dial barely moved you
know the these pressures
we're in a situation where we can we can
just about afford to do that there are
so many people who can't afford that and
that really worries me you know as we
head into the kind of the the the colder
months in the winter when people really
rely on on energy and things like that i
i just really worry that we're heading
into a really difficult period for so
many people
yes uh and uh we we know that with it's
hit about 100 pounds i think for an
average tank
to to fill a car um and the the eye just
very quickly we did touch on it
previously but no tax cuts but for two
years uh this is something that the
tory party have been uh paying for but
uh this has sealed it now that this is
not going to happen for about two years
and you know we we really thought they
were coming because for the past two or
three weeks there has been talk of tax
cuts and i and i think maybe we all
imagined i certainly did that rishi
would say something in the next two or
three months and for personal tax cuts
but but it's been made really clear now
that that's not gonna happen so that's
you know that's also maybe a lot of
people were kind of banking on that but
the problem for us all and it's exactly
what liam said i'm in exactly the same
position as him mine comes to an end in
about six or seven months time we all
probably borrowed more than we should
have done more than we could really
afford uh because the interest rates
were so pitifully wonderfully low um and
and now we're all gonna pay the price
yes i wish you soon
saying bringing forward income tax cuts
will stoke inflation further which is
the opposite of what he wants to achieve
let's have a look at the guardian um and
this is off the back of the resignation
of lord guys apparently
boris johnson the prime minister may
scrap the role of ethics advisor what
say you to that liam
i mean i mean why sort of keep keep the
pretence up you know nobody nobody
really understood why boris johnson had
an ethics advisor or should i say had
two ethics advisors both of whom
have uh resigned so he may as well just
be a bit honest with everyone and just
admit that he doesn't really have many
ethics to be advised upon
i mean it's such an embarrassing
situation for a prime minister it's
almost beyond beyond description he's
had he's now two ethics advisers one
anti-corruptions are all resigned on him
because they they can't feel that they
can justify their role around him so now
he's almost at the point where he's like
well why even bother and i can just do
whatever i want which is sort of i guess
how he kind of operates as prime
minister anyway this the whole situation
with law guy is deeply embarrassing it's
not it's not great for lord guy either
to be honest because i think a lot of
people feel that he should have resigned
earlier he should have responded
more strongly to the the sue grey report
you know if you were going to resign
over ethics i think that report would
have been the reason to do so i compared
it earlier to
um al capone being jailed for tax
evasion it just seems slightly odd that
low guy the ethics advisor has resigned
over over trade tariffs and not over the
the you know multiple lockdown breaches
that we saw in downing street but it's
just another low point in my opinion for
a prime minister that continues to plumb
the debts
how do you think it's another low point
or or
uh are people becoming accustomed to to
resignations away from boris johnson
i mean to be honest probably no one
no one out there probably knew who lord
guy was a couple of days ago now we do
and it's interesting that
this is bad for the tories because
people
this people just stopped talking about
boroughs having to resign you know that
you know the hubbub had just quietened
down and this has actually brought it
all back to that again but you know
liam's right in the sense that he should
have gone a long time ago even on monday
he was talking about having a six-month
extension to his job which seems very
bizarre to me because he he is saying
that um boris has put him in this this
odious position as he calls it he's
talking about partygate he thought boris
broke mr ministerial code over that um
and but but on happy even having thought
all that on monday he was still talking
about a six-month extension to his
contract so something's happened to
monday and now to to change that so you
know that to me all looks a bit weird
actually if he if he if he was so
morally affronted by bros he should have
gone a long time ago but but it is
interesting this is this is fodder for
all um boris's critics and the tories
critics because what they're what
they're just it's exactly davey came out
tonight and said more or less what liam
said he just said you know why bother
having an ethics adviser when you don't
have any ethics and that's going to be
repeated over and over again in the
papers tomorrow and it's a really bad
thing for downing street to say i think
at this time it makes them look very bad
because what they're saying is obviously
the ministerial code is going to be
upheld but they can't say how and if you
haven't got a ministerial an ethics
advisor who's going to uphold the code
or do you just is it just going to be an
ad hoc thing that's not a good look
either currently especially after
partygate and let's not forget that a
ministerial code that the prime minister
decided to rewrite himself so is he
sticking to his own code
technically the introduction he he
wrote before
technically
um let's let's uh go to the break
carolyn liam but stay right where you
are coming up this story on the front of
the star which warns brits not to drink
too much alcohol on what is meant to be
the hottest day of the year tomorrow
come back to us
[Music]
you are watching the press preview still
with me columnist carol malone and
political editor of the liverpool echo
liam thought oh carol isn't with us and
uh liam's joined and then oh they're
there
you'd swap sides and you're a blank
screen for a second there glad you're
back with us carol
let's have a look at the um ft uh and
this story on the front page about
ukraine's uh attempts to to join the eu
gathering further impetus from european
leaders who have been visiting
um ukraine today carrie you take us into
this story
yeah this is you know the leaves of
france germany italy and romania um went
to kiev today and they were talking to
president zielinski there was a very
there's i saw a photograph of a very
uncomfortable hug when macron who was
this is his one to do that he goes
around hugging leaders uh and he was
hugging zlensky who clearly didn't want
it to happen but anyway um and and and
they were talking about you know their
their all four countries have agreed to
put forward um
ukraine's candidacy to join the eu and
but it was made clear by the italian pm
today he said the pass from eu candidate
to member is a path not a point so not
what they're not saying that ukraine is
going to get in they get this they're
saying it's going to be a topic under
discussion but it was interesting today
macron said um
europe is at your side and will be for
as long as it takes which is very
interesting considering france was one
of the very last countries to give um
ukraine weapons and even now they're not
really handing that much over the only
country not to have declared exactly how
many weapons they've given and that's
because they've handed over a few howard
says as a as alone and they've gifted a
few shells not much more really typical
macron they just want to be seen as
being the leader of everything
this uh front page
could potentially further infuriate
putin though couldn't it liam
yeah and i think it does show
the sort of stage that we've got to now
because both macron and olaf schultz
that were almost sort of in the earlier
days
of the war were criticized in some ways
for a lack of a lack of action and a
lack of solidarity with ukraine whereas
the uk was actually praised in that in
that sense and and and some people
suggest that that's because
uh sort of central europe and western
europe is so reliant on on the gas
suppliers from
uh russia and when and they are now
actually experiencing some of the
difficulties because of that
um
this is a later a later visit than than
many of the other um
european and western leaders have made
but it almost it's almost to the point
now where it's like
yeah they've decided that that this is
the way they have to go they have to
back ukraine um russia have been
fought back um
admirably to into the donbass region and
now it's a case of it's almost like the
european leaders saying well
russia has to be defeated in this war
and to see
the italian prime minister uh the french
president
and and the german chancellor in that
same picture is quite a powerful image
actually and and i think
for zolensky it's an important moment
sometimes i think the war
moves off the front pages because we
move on but it's a reminder of what an
enormous geopolitical issue this still
remains indeed uh just time for this
story in the star being warned not to
drink too much on the hottest day of the
year but they're not talking about water
carol are they
do you know what these stories drive
because the star clearly didn't want to
go with inflation so they had to find
something to fill the front page and
this is the best i've been able to come
up with you know it's just ridiculous
it's just like such a nunnying thing to
say what most people want is a pint of
cold beer on a day like this or for the
rest of us a glass of wine um you know
if i want a glass of wine i'm going to
have one and the star's not going to
tell me otherwise but they liam quick
thought in 10 seconds
i i think my mum wrote this from paige
[Laughter]
my my irish mother she knows i've got
fair skin and she's always telling me to
drink water
and you should do as you're told liam
and carol thank you so much